all smiles to begin with dmitry medvedev
taking his seat for the president's
State of the Nation Address his face not
giving much away as the president
outlined a series of constitutional
reforms which would shift the balance of
power in Russia potentially providing a
role for Vladimir Putin when his
presidential term expires in 20 24 hours
later this surprise announcement
it is minyan year it is obvious that we
as the government of the Russian
Federation should provide the president
of our country with the opportunity to
make all the necessary decisions for
this therefore the current government of
the Russian Federation resigns the
government will stay on for now but mr.
Putin has already picked a new prime
minister the head of the federal tax
service Mikhail miss Euston he's not a
political heavyweight it's clear who
will be calling the shots which is how
it was with Medvedev - even during the
four years when the two men swap roles
President Medvedev's attempt at liberal
reform crushed when mr. Putin resumed
the presidency he made clear today that
he was not angling to stay on as
president the reconfiguration I think is
aimed at taking away power from the
presidency and empower other
institutions of russian government
management so that whatever position
putin means for himself would enable him
to be in control to be the ultimate
arbiter of the disputes among the elites
and of decision-making in the country it
may be that mr. Putin engineers himself
into the role of Prime Minister again
bolstered its power other suggestions
are that he might head up a beefed up
State Council either way it's clear he
will not be giving up control Diana
Magnay Sky News Moscow